compare the expressions on both sides of
the question mark so on the left hand
side of the question mark
I have 7,000 I have seven thousand nine
hundred and seven so it's seven thousand
plus nine hundred plus seven which is
going to be the same thing as seven
thousand nine hundred and seven now
let's compare that to what we have on
the right-hand side of the question mark
on the right hand side we have seven
thousand plus nine hundred seventy which
is seven thousand nine hundred and
seventy or we could if we wanted expand
it out we could write that as seven
thousand plus 900 plus seventy and then
we have zero ones so if we compare place
value by place value we have seven
thousand in either case so the thousands
place is the same we have the same
number of hundreds we have nine hundreds
but here we have no tens and we have a
seven and here we have no ones and we
have seventy and clearly seventy is
greater than seven so the number on the
right is greater than the number on the
left or the number on the left is less
than less than the number on the right I
always remember the less than symbol
because it points to the smaller number
or either of these symbols point to the
smaller number so this right over here
would mean greater than you have the
larger number on the left this is less
than you have the smaller number on the
left so we would go with less than this
is less than that